How can a very,
very interesting issue.
So this try and pick a couple of,
but the fact
it's evident to me,
and I'm enormously encouraged by this because I'm a passionate of Australia and
I'd want this country to be the sort of place that offers opportunities of the
salt that I had when I was young.
You know,
I've had my opportunities,
but I look at my kids' generation,
what's going to be there for them if we keep feeding the sort of scene grew in
reality,
the people turning out in vast numbers.
Every one of your talks in Australia's been oversubscribed massively.
It tells you that kind of get those more to this new way of being tall.
No.
Well,
it's one of the things that's so interesting about dealing with archetypal
themes know architectural themes are archetypal because they actually speak of
the structure of human experience.
That's why they last.
And so it's human nature and human experience has a pattern.
You don't have the capacity to do articulate that pattern as an individual in
part because your life is too short.
You just can't figure it out.
But the,
the ancient representations of those patterns are everywhere around you and you,
you know,
some of them at the image,
you caught on to them automatically you,
you,
you fall into them.
If you go to a movie for example,
because movies always express archetipal themes.
If you hear them articulate it,
you think,
I knew that,
I knew that.
I just didn't know how to say it.
That's,
that's the platonic idea of,
of,
uh,
of learning as remembering your,
your soul already knows,
but it doesn't have the words.
And so when people talk to me about watching my lectures,
let's say they say,
they basically say one of two things.
If,
if it,
if it's not just a simple thank you.
They say one of two things.
A third of them say,
quarter of them say,
when I listen to you talk,
it's as if you're telling me things that I already know.
It's like,
yeah,
well that's exactly right because that's what archetipal stories are there.
The description of what you already know,
but that can be articulated.
And then who you are and how you see yourself and the way you described yourself
all become the same thing.
So that's wonderful.
Then you're not at odds with yourself,
you know,
and then you have,
then you're a functioning unity and that makes you much stronger and more
indomitable than you would otherwise be.
And then the other thing that people say,
and this is more like three quarters of them,
is that they say,
I was in a very dark place.
I was addicted,
I was,
I was drinking too much.
I had a fragment,
did relationship with my fiance and I wasn't getting married.
Uh,
things weren't going very well with my family.
My relationship with my father was damaged.
I didn't have any AME.
I was wasting my time.
Some variant of that,
some combination of those.
And they say,
well,
I've been watching your lectures.
I've decided to establish a purpose.
I'm trying to tell the truth and things are way better.
And I've,
and so let's say I've done maybe eight or nine large scale public talks in the
last two months.
So that's probably 20,000 people.
And about half of them,
a third to half of the misstate afterwards to talk to me.
So that's about 7,000 people who have said that to me.
And then people stop me on the street all the time.
And tell me exactly that story,
which is just wonderful.
Like you can't imagine how good it is to be able to go to places you've never
been.
And to have people start people on the streets spontaneously and say,
look,
my life is way better than it was.
It's like,
it's so good.
And so,
and I've got like,
I don't know,
35,000 letters from people since last August.
It's more than that.
I can't keep track of them.
And it's exactly the same thing,
like three quarters,
quarter of them say,
well,
you've given me the words to say what I already knew it was true.
And thank you for that.
I can see that in the audience.
It's so interesting because I can lay out a story.
People go like this and say they're doing that all the time.
It's like the lights are going on.
And that's a really,
while there's no,
almost nothing better than that to watch lights go on when you're talking to
people,
it's like that's just absolutely fantastic.
But to get this response from people,
my father,
I have my father's about 80,
80 is 83,
I think 81 he's 81.
And uh,
I put it in charge of,
of going through my viewer email,
um,
which is an overwhelming job.
But now he,
we've had discussions about this constantly.
He's overwhelmed by the fact that so many people are writing and saying the same
thing.
It's like,
well,
I have a purpose in my life actually matters.
I finally realized that and I'm putting it into practice and I'm bearing up
under the heaviest load I can imagine.
And it's really helping.
It's like God,
and that's tens of thousands of responses now.
So it's,
it's,
you couldn't hope for anything better than that.
There's zero harm in it,
right?
It's just people putting their lives together,
they're not mucking about with other people and are trying to make broad scale
social transformations about which they have no idea.
They're trying to make their immediate environment better and it's working.
It's like great,
great.
You say the zero harm in it.
I would say as a former legislator that there's an enormous amount of good in a
country is only,
there's some title of the people would make it.
Um,
to the extent that they put together resilient,
I would only contribute,
don't have to ask others to help them.
The stronger the nation.
Yes.
And rapidly like,
I mean I think I was thinking the other day some,
a journalist asked me why the audience,
why people are responding so positively to what I'm saying,
the young men for example.
And I thought,
hmm,
why,
why?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
So it's,
well I'm actually on their side.
I'm pretty happy that I'm really happy that they're not wasting their lives.
I'm really sad to see that people are disenchanted and nihilistic and depressed
and anxious and aimless and,
and perverse and vengeful and,
and all of those things.
It's terrible.
And then to see people question whether that's necessary and then to start to
rise out of it,
it's like,
it's so fun.
Like last night I was at after my talk.
It's overwhelming.
Okay.
I don't usually think about these things,
but I was,
I was after my talk last night,
didn't.
So all these people line up and you know,
they have their fifteens 15 seconds with me and they're kind of tentative.
They're excited and attentive when they come up to talk to me and then they
have,
you know,
15 seconds of time to tell me something.
I'm really listening to them and they're hesitant about whether or not to share
the good news about their life.
You know?
And I think it's often because,
okay,
when people share good news about their life,
people don't necessarily respond positively.
You know,
they don't get encouragement and people need so little encouragement.
It's just unbelievable.
And so they'll tell me something good and nothing,
God,
that's so good.
You know,
somebody says,
oh,
I'm getting along way better with my father.
I haven't seen him for 10 years and now we get along.
It's like crate.
And the,
the,
the power of that,
you can't overstate the power of that for individuals to get their life
together.
They individuals an unbelievably powerful force.
And every single person who gets their act together a little bit has the
capacity to spread that around them.
It's,
it's a chain reaction.
And so it's a lovely thing to see and that's fantastic.